‏soly ising kind of
difficult going is making that we can
accommodate them if we have to walk
their car somebody someh the person has
to be here want to make sure we are
taking
care ‏e
[Silence]
‏ne
صلاه القيام اثابكم
الله
استووا استووا
[Silence]
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ين
امين ان الذين امنوا والذين هادوا
والنصارى والصابئين من امن بالله واليوم
الاخر وعمل صالحا فلهم اجرهم
فلهم اجرهم عند ربهم ولا خوف عليهم ولا هم
يحزنون واذ اخذنا ميثاقكم ورفعنا فوقكم
الطور خذوا ما اتيناكم بقوه واذكروا ما
فيه لعلكم
تتقون ثم توليتم من بعد ذلك فلولا فضل
الله عليكم ورحمته لكنتم من
الخاسرين ولقد علمتم الذين اعتدوا منكم في
السبت فقلنا لهم كونوا قرده
خاسئين فجعلناها نكالا لما بين يديها وما
خلفها وموعظه
للمتقين واذ قال موسى لقومه ان الله
يامركم ان تذبحوا
بقره قالوا اتتخذنا هزوا قال اعوذ بالله
ان اكون من
الجاهلين قالوا ادع لنا ربك يبين لنا ما
هي قال انه يقول انها بقره لا فارض ولا
بكر عوان بين ذلك
فافعلوا ما
تؤمرون قالوا ادع لنا ربك يبين لنا ما
لونها قال انه يقول انها بقره
صفراء فاقع لونها تسر
الناظرين الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قالوا ادع لنا ربك يبين لنا ما هي ان
البقر تشابه علينا وانا ان شاء الله
لمهتدون
قال انه يقول انها بقره لا لا ذلول تثير
الارض ولا تسقي الحرث مسلمه لا شيه
فيها قالوا الان جئت بالحق فذبحوها وما
كادوا
يفعلون واذ قتلتم نفسا فاداراتم
فيها والله مخرج ما كنتم
تكتمون فقلنا اضربوه
ببعضها كذلك يحيي الله الموتى ويريكم
اياته لعلكم
تعقلون ثم قست
قلوبكم من بعد ذلك فهي كالحجاره او اشد
قسوه وان من الحجاره لما يت وان من
الحجاره لما يتفجر منه
الانهار وان منها لما يشقق فيخرج منه
الماء وان منها لما يهبط من خشيه
الله وما الله بغافل
عما
تعملون افتطمعون ان يؤمنوا لكم وقد كان
فريق منهم يسمعون كلام الله ثم
يحرفونه من بعد ما عقلوه وهم
يعلمون واذا لقوا الذين امنوا قالوا
امنا واذا خلى بعضهم الى بعض قالوا
اتحدثونهم بما فتح الله عليكم
ليحاجوكم
به عند
ربكم افلا
تعقلون اولا يعلمون ان الله يعلم ما يسرون
وما
يعلنون الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
ال الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
ومنهم
اميون لا يعلمون الكتاب الا اماني وان هم
الا
يظنون فويل للذين يكتبون الكتاب بايديهم
ثم يقولون هذا من عند الله ليشتروا به
ليشتروا به ثمن
قليلا فويل لهم مما كتبت ايديهم وويل لهم
مما
يكسبون وقالوا لن تمسنا النار الا اياما
معدوده قل اتخذتم عند الله عهدا فلن يخلف
الله عهده ام تقولون على الله ما لا
تعلمون
بلى من كسب سيئه واحاطت به
خطيئته
فاولئك اصحاب النار هم فيها
خالدون والذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
اولئك اصحاب
الجنه هم فيها
خالدون واذ اخذنا ميثاق بني اسرا
ئيل لا تعبدون الا الله وبالوالدين
احسانا وبالوالدين
احسانا وذي القربى واليتامى والمساكين
وقولوا للناس حسنا واقيموا
الصلاه واقيموا الصلاه واتوا
الزكاه ثم توليتم الا قليلا منكم وان انتم
معرضون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن ال الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
واذ اخذنا ميثاقكم لا تسفكون
دماءكم ولا تخرجون انفسكم من
دياركم ثم اقررتم وانتم
تشهدون ثم انتم هؤلاء
تقتلون انفسكم وتخرجون فريقا منكم من
ديارهم تظاهرون عليهم بالاثم
والعدوان وان ياتوكم اسارى تفادوهم وهو
محرم عليكم
اخراجهم افتؤمنون ببعض الكتاب وتكفرون
ببعض فما جزا
من يفعل ذلك منكم الا خزي في الحياه
الدنيا ويوم القيامه يردون الى اشد
العذاب وما الله بغافل عما
تعملون اولئك الذين اشتروا الحياه الدنيا
بالاخره فلا يخفف عنهم العذاب ولا
فلا يخفف عنهم العذاب ولا هم
ينصرون ولقد اتينا موسى الكتاب وقفينا من
بعده
بالرسل واتينا عيسى ابن مريم البينات
وايدناه بروح القدس افكلما
جاءكم رسول بما لا تهوى
انفسكم
استكبرتم ففريقا كذبتم وفريقا
تقتلون وقالوا قلوبنا غلف بل لعنهم الله
بكفرهم فقليلا ما
يؤمنون الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
لام
‏some
‏as donation as
as1 which are your
compation may be a to mat those so pleas
check that something doesn't cost you
anything what
to comp
does second part we noty
‏toad and bally no c to you all
doal and what
are
coun liability that you have st any so
we have exp that before there any
question pleas
to here
‏form com s s
u of
[Silence]
‏ta yes yes yes so that's a very good
clarification of you have asked me if i
pay now where does can i apply to the
last year taxes and the answer is yes so
in other words when you do april 15th
the taxes you can make that you
providing the funds to the r academy but
immediately that is covering your
liability to
‏hope
c بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه والسلام
على رسول الله و اله وصحبه ومن ومن تبع
باحسان الى يوم الدين بعد just quickly on
to was being mention there is talk
throughout last
year
how how
my
‏where av and how things are nationally
locally state the need for having a
school that prot kids is to
pri and here i think conversations coule
of people
here 10 right here
ta that's
[Silence]
‏as
يه الله مو عليه
يه
howest
props عليه وسلم
[Silence]
عليهه
الله
عل اله الله رول
[Silence]
come more
موسى
عليهه اني لما انزلت اليه منير
فقير مون
[Silence]
جز اذب الى فرعون انه
تون
one
mur minded
[Silence]
عليه عليهه
عليهن
كثير م
عليه sl
[Silence]
‏ord there
ising so he says you
know and his wife yous at says know
with you know as parents
‏iny and jum on
and on
bells and a small baby not even that
heavy but you
know time or the angle so they put two
in
fronts and and
one from
far
عليه
‏which
there
gu the
js allah made c job is right so
the please diver him from he grabs
a and then he puts it in
mouth right and of course at that time
you know ran and took the
baby you know
[Silence]
‏from burn so
there is
as
was way ‏people actually
have in english in regular
langage them will
be seen people like
person i don't one
from some me they seen ofr there is
their flow when they becomes but anye in
musa's case
[Silence]
رحي صدر ويسرلي امري واحل لقده من لساني
يفقه قولي
[Silence]
ا حه بالله العظ
‏me ي ص
my
make can i
can tos it
رحي صدر ويسرلي
ام وحقده لسان
يفق as
[Silence]
اعلي
‏i me you know he say you he my protect
he helps me right and
also he has
he
a and explain the difference between two
while back if not
clearly is one
been ta
حون
عل
ش
عليه الله سبحانه
وتالى عل
‏graan
was
anye and make
kids every scho in the
them you think
[Silence]
سال
‏any and that he fores brs and sisters
and and un
and اله اللهب
[Silence]
‏ch ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره
حسنه و عذاب النار ونا عذاب القب ونا عبنم
ونا فتحت وتسح ال ربنا تقبل منا انك انت
السميع العليم وتوب علينا يا مولانا ك
تواب الرحيم وصلى الله على محمد وعلى اله
وصحبه اجمعين برحمتك ارحم الراحمين اللهم
امين اللهم امين اللهم
[Silence]
امين استقيم واعتدل استو
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
ولما
جاءهم كتاب من عند الله مصدق لما
معهم وكانوا من قبل يستفتحون على الذين
كفروا فلما
جاءهم ما عرفوا كفروا به فلعنه الله على
الكافرين بئس ما اشتروا به
انفسهم ان
يكفروا ان يكفروا بما انزل الله بغيا ان
ينزل الله من فضله على من
يشاء ان ينزل الله من فضله على من يشاء من
عباده
فباءوا بغضب على غضب
وللكافرين عذاب مهين واذا قيل لهم امنوا
بما انزل الله
قالوا قالوا نؤمن بما انزل علينا ويكفرون
بما
وراءه وهو الحق مصدقا لما
معهم قل فلم تقتلون
انبياء الله من قبل ان
كنتم مؤمنين
ولقد
جاءهم موسى
بالبينات ولقد
جاءكم موسى
بالبينات ثم اتخذتم العجل من بعده ثم
اتخذتم العجل من بعده وانتم
ظالمون واذ اخذنا ميثاق
ورفعنا فوقكم الطور خذوا ما
اتيناكم
بقوه خذوا ما
بقوه
واسمعوا قالوا سمعنا
وعصينا واشربوا في قلوبهم العجل
بكفرهم قل بئس ما
يامركم به
ايمانكم ان
كنتم
مؤمنين الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
قل ان كانت لكم الدار الاخره عند الله
خالصه من دون
الناس
فتمنوا الموت ان كنتم
صادقين ولن
يتمنوه ابدا بما قدمت
ايديهم والله عليم
الظالمين
ولتجدنهم احرص الناس على حياه ومن الذين
اشركوا ومن الذين اشركوا يود احدهم لو
يعمر الف سنه وما هو بمزحزحه من
العذاب وما هو بمزحزحه من عذاب ان
يعمر والله
بصير بما
يعملون قل من كان عدوا لجبريل فانه نزله
على قلبك باذن
الله مصدقا لما بين يديه
وهدى وبشرى
للمؤمنين من كان عدوا لله
وملائكته ورسله وجبريل
وميكال وجبريل وميكال
فان الله عدو
للكافرين ولقد
انزلنا اليك
ايات
بينات وما يكفر بها الا
الفاسقون
اوكلما عاهدوا عهدا نبذه فريق
منهم بل
اكثرهم لا
يؤمنون الله
اكبر سمع الله الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولما
جاءهم رسول من عند الله مصدق لما
معهم مصدق لما معهم نبذ فريق من الذين
اتوا الكتاب كتاب الله وراء
ظهورهم
كانهم لا
يعلمون واتبعوا ما تتلو الشياطين على ملك
سليمان وما كفر سليمان
ولكن الشياطين
كفروا يعلمون الناس السحر وما انزل على
الملك كين بباب ل هاروت
وماروت وما يعلمان من احد حتى يقلا
انما نحن فتنه
انما نحن
فتنه فلا تكفر
فيتعلمون منهما ما يفرقون به بين المرء
وزوجه وما هم
بضارين به من احد الا باذن
الله
ويتعلمون ما يضرهم ولا
ينفعهم ولقد علموا لمن اشتراه ما له في
الاخره من
خلاق ولبئس ما شروا به
انفسهم لو كانوا
يعلمون ولو
انهم امنوا واتقوا
لمثوبه من عند الله
خير لو كانوا
يعلمون يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تقولوا
راعنا وقولوا انظرنا
واسمعوا
وللكافرين عذاب
اليم ما يود الذين كفروا من اهل الكتاب
ولا المشركين ان ينزل
عليكم ان ينزل عليكم من خير من
ربكم والله يختص
برحمته من
يشاء
والله ذو الفضل العظيم
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
بسم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط مستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ما ننسخ من ايه او ننسها نات بخير
منها او
مثلها الم تعلم ب الم تعلم ان الله على كل
شيء
قدير الم تعلم ان الله له ملك السماوات
والارض وما لكم من دون الله من ولي ولا
نصير ام تريدون ان تسالوا رسولكم كما سئل
موسى من قبل ومن يتبدل الكفر بالايمان فقد
ضل
سواء السبيل ود كثير من اهل الكتاب لو
يردونكم من بعد
ايمانكم كفارا
حسدا حسدا من عند
انفسهم من بعد ما تبين لهم الحق
فاعفوا واصفحوا حتى ياتي الله
بامره ان الله على كل شيء قدير واقيموا
الصلاه واتوا الزكاه وما تقدموا
لانفسكم من خير تجدوه عند
الله ان الله بما تعملون
بصير وقالوا لن يدخل
الجنه الا من كان هودا او
نصارى تلك
امانيهم قل هاتوا
برهانكم ان كنتم
صادقين بلى من اسلم وجهه لله وهو محسن فله
اجره عن عند ربه فله اجره عند ربه ولا خوف
عليهم ولا هم
يحزنون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله st
شف ان شاء الله الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين سبح اسم ربك الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى
والذي والذي قدر فهدى والذي اخرج المرعى
فجعله
غثاء
احوى سنقرئك فلا
تنسى الا ما شاء
الله
انه يعلم الجهر وما يخفى وينس
ونيسرك
لليسرى فذكر
انفعت
الذكرى سيذكر من يخشى
ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى النار
الكبرى ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من
تزكى وذكر اسم ربه
فصلى بل تؤثرون الحياه
الدنيا
والاخره خير
وابقى ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى صحف
ابراهيم
وموسى الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعم عمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين بسم الله
ال قل اعوذ برب الناس
ال ملك
الناس اله
الناس من شر الوسواس
الخناس الذي يوسوس في صدور
الناس من
الجنه
والناس الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم و رحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
stil ver vende
caps at the end of the
دعا ان شاء
الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك عبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
بسم
الله قل هو الله
احد الله
الصمد لم يلد ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده اللهم انت الحق ووعدك الحق ولقاؤك
الحق وجنه الحق ونار الحق ونبي حق ونبينا
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم حق اللهم بك
اسلمنا وعليك تو وكلنا وبك خسم واليك نبنا
فاغفر لنا ما قدمنا وما اخرنا فانت المقدم
وانت الموخر وانت على كل شيء
قدير اللهم اهدنا في منن هديت وعافنا في
من عافيت وتولنا فيمن
توليت وبارك لنا فيما اعتيت
وكنا واصرف عنا برحمتك شر ما قضيت انك
تقضي ولا يقضى عليك انه لا يزل من واليت
ولا يعز من
عاديت تباركت ربنا
وتعاليت اللهم اغفر لنا
ذنوبنا اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا وان لم تغفر
لنا
وترحمنا لنكونن من
الخاسرين اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعفو
عنا اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعفو عنا
اللهم انك عفو كريم تحب العفو
فعفونا اللهم اعتق رقابنا من النار
ورقاب
والدينا
وذريتنا
وازواجنا
وارحمنا
وامهاتنا
وابائنا
ومشايخنا من النار وادخلنا جنه مع
الابرار يا عزيز يا
غفار اللهم في هذه الليله
المباركه لا تدع لنا ذنبا الا غفرت ولا
هما الا
فرجت ولا مريضا الا
شفيت ولا دينا الا
قضيته ولا اولادا الا
اصلحته ولا اولادا الا
اصلحت ولا اولادا الا الا اصلحت ولا ضالا
الا هديت ولا
ضالا الا هديت ولا
ضالا الا
هديت ولا عيبا الا
سطرت ولا ميتا الا
رحمت ولا حاجه من الدنيا والاخره هي لك
رضى ولنا قضيتها ويسرتها لنا اللهم يا
سامع الصوت ويا سابق الفوت ويا كاسيا عظام
لحما بعد الموت اغفر لجميع الموتى
المسلمين الذين شهدك
بالوحدانيه ونبينا
بالرساله وماتوا على ذلك اللهم اغفر لهم
وارحمهم وعافهم واعفو عنهم واكرم نزلهم
ووسع مدخلهم واغسلهم بالماء ثلج والبرد
ونقيه من الذنوب والخطايا كما ينقى الثوب
الابيد من
النس اللهم عز
جارك وجل ثناؤك وتقدست اسماك اللهم لا يرد
امرك ولا يحزن جندك اللهم عيد المسجد
الاقصى الى رحاب المسلمين اللهم عيد
المسجد الاقصى الى رحاب المسلمين اللهم
عيد المسجد الاقصى الى رحاب المسلمين
وارزقنا فيه صلاه قبل الممات اللهم انت
الاسلام
والمسلمين اللهم انصر اخوان المستضعفين في
كل مكان
انصر اخوان المستضعفين في فلسطين وغزه وفي
السودان وفي السين وفي برما وكشمير والهند
وكل
مكان اللهم ايدهم بجنودك لا يعلم جنودك
الا
انت اللهم زل الشرك والمشركين ودمر اعداء
الدين يا قوي يا
عزيز يا حي يا قيوم
يا حي يا قيوم يا حي يا قيوم برحمتك
نستغيث اسلح لنا شاننا كله ولا تكلنا الى
انفسنا طرفه
عين اللهم اسلح اولادنا واولاد المسلمين
اللهم اصلح احوالنا واحوال
المسلمين اللهم اصلح بيوتنا وبيوت
المسلمين اللهم تقبل منا صيامنا وقيامنا
وقراننا وصلاتنا
وزكاتنا اللهم لا تجعل القران حجه علينا
واجعل حجه لنا يا رب
العالمين اللهم ذكرنا منه ما
نسينا وعلمنا منه ما جهلنا وارزقنا تلاوه
اناء الليل واطراف النهار على الوجه الذي
يرضيك عن النار يا عزيز يا
غفار لا اله الا انت سبحانك كنا من
الظالمين لا اله الا انت سبحانك انا كنا
من الظالمين لا اله الا انت سبحانك انا
كنا من
الظالمين ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي
الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب النار وقنا عذاب
القبر وكنا عذاب جهنم وكنا شر فتنه محيا
والممات وكنا شر فتنه مسيح
الدجال ربنا تقبل منا انك انت السميع
العليم وتب علينا يا موان انك انت التواب
الرحيم وصلى الله على محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
[Silence]
اجمعين الله
اكبر ا